of course here in los angeles most
businesses are still closed
museums are closed gyms are closed bars
are still shut down
now i'm fine with gyms and museums being
closed
never went but having all the bars shut
down
that's rough i really miss going to a
bar
grabbing a drink with friends meeting
new people
fortunately true story there is a bar
right here at the largo theater it's in
the next room across the courtyard
it's a pretty famous cool spot so i
figured
there is a way that i can go right now
and have a drink with some friends but
do it
safely so andy you stay here with the
cardboard cutouts
i'm going to a bar okay boss
i'm gonna get myself a drink
right in here
it is great to be back
hey there's chad the bartender he's
always happy to see me
you talking to me oh you want your drink
sure i'll slide it to you
[Music]
oh cool they still have that jukebox
and that woman who's always staring at
me
okay
that's great people are just happy to be
out and about
that guy really likes his beer yeah
good beer cool
yeah yeah
yeah thumbs up to beer wow
that guy really likes his beer
god i really missed this crowd
check out that guy he lost everything on
bitcoin
oh cheers ladies
yeah wow
she was nice hey there i'm conan
i host the show
not a fan do you
come here often i said do you come here
often
god now i know i don't come here i hate
this place
ladies stop looking at me and get some
help hey
and freak stop with the thumbs up just a
[ __ ] beer
damn even when covet ends i'm never
coming to a bar again
we got a great show ted danson's here
bars
[Music]
great show